this has to feel amazing right now I can
kind of see it the reaction already
through your body language how are you
feeling I'm as surprised and really
excited and yeah a little emotional I
don't know it's all the feelings what
does it mean to win for the hamate tails
though this story in particular so much
I mean I'm so fortunate to be a part of
such an incredible company of actors and
to get to tell this story now it's just
such an honor people have had such
strong reactions to it at a husband at
home and I'm sure your family's so proud
how are you guys gonna celebrate this
win I don't know I don't know I can't I
still can't believe I won I think I'm
still sort of in that headspace we
talked to a couple of your cast mates on
The Handmaid's Tale and they all only
told us that it's going to get darker
there right I don't think it's darker if
you can imagine that and yeah I mean I
I'm so on board for anything that Bruce
Miller imagines I mean he's just an
incredible writer and I'm again just so
fortunate to get to play this character
who's just incredibly strong and just I
love the way her mind works and to just
to get to delve into that again I I
can't wait to see what we get to do
[Music]
you